good
morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toasty hey this is officially
over we came back extra early because I
could truly felt as if I had no purpose
in this world and I really was missing
the toasters and just like getting back
into my everyday routine and obviously
needed to come here promote leasing oh
so this is a number one morning show
like I don't even need to do press for
this thing I'll cuz like the test is
press its Good Morning America yeah I'm
very excited to be back it has been
quite I hate its Jackie's back tomorrow
she's on her way home she also she just
like had to get back to her cut her trip
short she's a business woman she knows
where she's needed and she won't be back
in time for my party tonight and I just
really feel like it's an episode of my
super sweet 16 anyway and you know it's
like today of and they're like filming
them like getting a facial like any legs
like you're wearing a sparkly dress no I
know go into your sweet 16 you invited
everyone that you've ever invited
everyone that I've ever met because you
know what it's like when you think in
theory like having a party's fun but
it's actually not and it's fun for
everyone except for you and I just I
have found myself in the past few years
whether it's like throwing parties like
for my birthday or just like work things
like it's super hard to get like bodies
in a room it's impossible to get bodies
like when someone's like a hundred
people like that's impossible to me yeah
and it's like when you get a great venue
that's like super spacious it's like you
don't even want that because even if 50
people show up it looks like five people
and then it's sad and scattered and yes
I just awkward I don't want it to be sad
it's got her party I've been soul is
abenney big no it's actually like a
great size meet you it's a beautiful
venue I'm really excited for everyone to
see it I'm really just like invest and I
really think this party together like
last minute um I was able to get pop
stock it said time which I'm really
excited about I have my cover art on the
back so just let me rewind really
quickly I don't know if I've mentioned
this like maybe one or 65 thousand times
but I'm coming out with a song it's been
a really long labor of love it's been
about a year I'm supposed to release it
on my birthday but it just wasn't quite
ready and I'm so glad that I waited
because the song is so much better it's
in such a better place I've been teasing
it on my Instagram a bunch I'm tonight
is the launch party the song comes out
tonight at midnight Spotify iTunes
everywhere you can buy it I'm an
independent artist who's just like
trying to own her own masters I'm
inspired by Taylor Swift right I think
like this is the but I actually haven't
been so excited about like a work thing
in so long like this
this song has been my life for the last
two weeks yeah it's what I did year for
the last year but like really the last
two weeks like pushing out getting song
finished getting artwork made throwing a
party having figuring out how to
distribute to iTunes and Spotify when
you don't have a record label is like
super hard and expensive but I'm just so
glad I just know like the clocks gonna
strike midnight tonight and like the
song won't be there because like that's
what happens to my life you know that
happen to our lives that's what happens
did you wear that shirt cuz hunt it down
you're gonna have a good time I were to
share for a lot of reasons one because I
just got it and I got it I mean I stole
it from someone - it's really just like
the the mindset I want to go into today
with like this song is all about just
like [ __ ] throwing dollars down and
getting toasted with your friends so
it's definitely emulating lots of lyrics
it's it's an easter egg of sort oh okay
there's so much that you're literally
you're like Easter egg here all of the
lyrics to my dough I know it's not like
an easter egg because Easter eggs are
supposed to be like oh yeah but I don't
care okay no I just like I have created
the pop star I wish to see in the world
totally and I feel like I'm very much on
the way to becoming the first ever like
pop star comedian I mean you're
definitely the first pop star comedian
look if this song like does well and
people want more like I will definitely
release more songs but I think that if
people don't like if the reception it's
just not there and like people like okay
this was cool I like don't ever do it
again I'm not gonna do me like what if
you like go number one stop I mean what
if you're the one to take down Old Town
Road my girl I really feel like you're
just like blowing my head up like so big
sorry but the song is like a big plate
for my friend Jason yesterday I really
just like have played it for a few
people and what people say first they're
shocked that it's like a real good song
Claudia I keep playing it for my friends
and like they're all like I thought it
was a joke they don't mean in a bad way
they're like I just didn't think it was
me a real song no I know and then they
hear you know that's the part and then
they're just like oh [ __ ] like this is a
legitimate song and I'm like hell yeah
it is and people like me I did some
press yesterday like people keep asking
me like why I wrote a song and really
the answer is like I really wrote this
for the toaster it's like I want us to
have a song that like is ours like
legally first of all like I own the song
so I can don't have to pay like a
copyright EP any time I play it on the
toast - but it's like we are such a
community that's like so built on the
foundation
like pre-gaming with good music and like
having a good time like music can really
make you feel like a different way
glad so I just wanted to be a part of
that in some way I just wanted to give
this gift of the gift of music to the
toasters the gift of song and I am just
like I can't believe like I actually did
it just like I can't believe you're
gonna be on Spotify yeah no I know like
how cool is that so cool are justö
[ __ ] cool so yeah it's just
gonna be great a the song comes out at
midnight Eastern Time so lucky for the
couple and God willing I think that's 9
o'clock and I'm just I'm thrilled I'm
just so excited so blessed really
excited for the party I'm wearing a
sparkly dress I'm going legs bare which
I feel is as if that's very brave of me
like on my own party like I'm just
showing the world my legs right I'm not
the type of girl you know it's like get
to know me first and then I'll show you
my legs yeah um but I've actually I knew
that I was gonna show my legs so I've
been taking extra good care of my legs
like the past week because I'm like over
again expert chance they get like too
lumpy
yeah and I found myself scrubbing my
legs so hard so I've been doing like a
tinted moisturizer for like a week and I
definitely see a difference I just want
to do that I don't want to learn how to
do so I got the products like a week ago
because we partnered with this new
company called hope bronze and there's a
ton of products but the one that I
really liked is like the gradual
moisturizer so first of all I never firm
ember to moisturize my legs so this this
way I'm remembering to do like an
important thing like hot bronze
moisturize my legs but then I'm also
getting tan which like I will literally
do anything to get tan so they have a
ton of products they have tan and Amit
which is a one-time you submit that's
readily infused as self tanning formula
which is really good they have Sun
dropped serums which you add a few drops
to your face and body moisturizer for a
natural looking tan that's really good
for travel because you can't bring like
a big thing of moisturizer with you they
have faced towels Olivia who loves the
face towels that when I got a whole
package I sent them all to her she loves
them tantowels easy to apply SEP self
tanning towelettes that come in three
shades light/medium dark you see I use
them in high school too you basically
just like rub it on your face and you
wake up in your tan it's truly magic it
really i need the body glow which is
what I've been using a gradual tanner
formulated with shea butter and the
perfect amount of self tanning formula
for a subtle buildable glow so the the
the moisturizer that I use smells like
crack like it's so good and I guess it's
shea butter I literally didn't even know
that
so I'm obsessed with hope bronze I think
you guys will be too you can
that just back from vacation summer is
here glow without bronze a new self
tanning line for the face and body with
five products that give you a truly
natural looking tan absolutely no Sun
required it is a second brand from the
founder of tantowel who invented the
original self tanning towelette gel so
that we can get an at-home tan without
being streaky smelly and orange because
that's the worst so used code Toth 24
shop to shop all your self-tanning needs
at Hope bronzed calm
that's code totes 20 I really highly
recommend this brand and I would have
known about it if it weren't for Olivia
and the yest so I'd remember in high
school she was using those tantowels ya
know it's just waiting to say I hope you
like I've done so many things over the
years like look tan and I definitely
looked crazy at some points in my life
and I feel like I'm at a good place
right now with all my tanning products
yeah is there anything else you want to
catch up on like what's with you so much
has happened in the past like two weeks
and went to the live method for the
first time yesterday okay well he
because he was being psycho texted me
every day he was like I want to go and
then the method is the gym that Margot
Olivia and Jackie now use um definite
like apparently change their lives it's
just like not for me but I'm really
happy for you guys know it really
honestly has changed my life and I mean
that in every way possible and somebody
have been going I'm honestly so excited
to just see him go and like he threw up
yesterday I know but honestly a lot of
people do no eyes normal for like a
brief period I did a personal trainer at
Equinox and the first day I threw out my
Cheerios yeah like that and they
honestly like we're still fully like
circles and I was confused like why why
didn't you my food like inhaled a yeah
I'm excited to see like a month from now
like where Ben's at so that's it that's
always exciting I went to the Nike store
oh I know and he bought like a headband
and wristbands and when he threw up he
took the wristbands and put them under
his needs as knee pads and he said it
helped so much no I'm sure it hurts when
your knees are that's the hardest part
agreed I'm the sweating people who throw
up like on their feet are sociopaths we
that's not possible people stand them
like lean over yeah but you're so far
away from the table I know you're making
that up no I swear people to it and it's
like so much splashback just something
to think about that's so disgusting
how can you aim like that I don't just
go I know I don't even go mania said
literally sit like on my ass spread
eagle like I just do it like I or like I
like this is the toilet yes right I'm
just like hey ya know I've just become
so
and three gap which is so sad I'm truly
I'm the case of the tipsy toaster ice
knock on wood because like we're
partying today but happy they're not in
a really long time
oh I threw up in the Hamptons but it
wasn't my fault like you know one can
not throw up in the Hamptons like you
drink and then to get home it's like 20
minutes on Kirby dark roads
who wouldn't throw up I'm like in the
back of the zubur with my eyes rolling
behind my head I'm like and everything
is so far from each other everything is
so far I was at Gurney's I was going
back to East Hampton which is
technically like close for the Hamptons
30-minute drive in the back of an uber
all by myself I'm like this guy I was
like literally rolling around the back
like I was out alive I was a ball of
mush and I'm thinking I'm like this guy
totally like the fact that I made it
home I woke up the next day and I was
like really grateful like that guy
totally could have kidnapped me like in
the middle of the boonies no cell phone
service like he could have taken me
wherever he wants so what do they have
ever since I get with the time they have
you got everyone dead everyone cool
comes to you they need their phone it's
such torture and people love it they're
like a love to unplug like no I want to
take pictures
not even that just like the worst it's
like when you're just on your phone more
than you would be because you're not
getting service of course and then your
battery gets so low because you're
constantly looking for service and that
waste that absolutely yeah it's insane
but when I was OC 100 I was on z1 -
Margo Basanti 100 is airing next Friday
that's Friday how was that that was like
your first like ever alone interview and
it's like did it really have to do z100
my first one like it's literally been
keeping me up at night I'm just scared
like if I said anything bad go here but
I brought in with Nicole with me just
like to have someone like you know to be
able to retrace things and I said as
well and she said that I was like
perfectly fine whatever everybody
hundred it's like an iconic radio
station we used to listen it's at a
prime time Friday night at 9:00 p.m.
like that's what everyone's in an uber
know Margo we used to like call z100
like trying to look winning contests all
the time one eight hundred two four two
zero one hundred I literally will never
forget I used to call like a million is
call a million times and they you get on
the radio like request a song you like
this one's her Margo you know we were
obsessing obsessing it so I got to come
full circle for songs when you choose
well Jay ruin it no actually yeah okay
no one okay yours by Andy Grammer
no yours Oh oh my god that is so sweet
I'm begging to play it yeah it's gonna
be on on the radio did you not know this
no I think you were just like choosing
your songs that you love or knew they
play them like it's like a it's like
which one oh my god I'm so [ __ ] to my
core I'm gonna be on C 100 maybe it's
like get in the car weird listen to do
well I'm sure like on the I heart app
maybe like you can't need to get into a
car fit we'll get a spare it's from any
time between nine and ten I believe
called in over for an hour and we'll
just sit in the car
oh my god that is so nice actually not
know that is reacting more I swear I
didn't know that they were gonna plug it
well you just think I spoke about it
yeah oh well I spoke about it and it's
being played number one on my countdown
give me one of your songs I mean how
could I not I'm literally going on the
radio and your song comes out I need to
just like put it out there like if you
work for a radio station like please
play my song I don't have a label and
there's a release into radio isn't that
a whole other ballgame I have no idea
I'm just hoping like there's enough you
know streams like someone at you know
Clear Channel just like right but it's
like with the Kacey Musgraves son I'll
show you the most dreams ever and they
would never play her on the radio
there's definitely some sort of politics
I know obviously I prefer streams over
radio plays but it's just like cool to
be on the radio but I guess it will be
you will be that is so cool I can't
believe you didn't know that I'm so
happy for you and for me ya know that I
am
thank you I won't sing cuz if I'm gonna
sing it's gonna be honey time we're
gonna have a good time
a dozen hands up to the sky we go and
get toasty tonight I've been feeling it
all damn well you know what yeah let's
feel it I don't tease yeah I don't want
this to the well okay it's just it's
very exciting
okay so I do believe I'm not a hundred
percent sure that it might be time oh
it's been fifteen minutes I think it's
time you think it's time you know we
have a lot to do after this we have to
go set up for the party I got custom
M&Ms that I need to bring down I was
your face on them
no it's just the word toast okay I mean
like my cool font from the album cover I
made I like I uploaded a picture of my
face on that man and I'm like this is
too stupid it's like I'm doing a lot for
this song but I never want to cross the
line into being like a joke that and
stupid yeah no I understand you have to
let me know like that's why people are
you gonna perform at the party I'm like
honestly no like maybe I'll get on the
mic and just like sing along but like if
I had like a stage and stuff like I just
don't want to see a stupid ya know I can
just like see I can't that's where it
starts to feel like an episode of my
super sweet 16 yeah or like if everyone
go outside I'm like the dad brings a car
to me yeah alright we'll see we'll edit
yeah well edit as we go just like tell
me when I'm starting to feel stupid okay
okay you tell me when you're talking to
feel I'll tell you when you're starting
to look okay so I believe that without
further ado it is time finally to
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast you
don't have to do it it's like there's a
sound effect no that I know but I just
want to go along with the sound effects
yeah but I heard hit and you were like a
second before so you just like ruin the
entire experience for everyone I just
wanted to tell you no no no no shade you
should just let go and my god can you
explain why did you brought me a water
in this ugly brown cup and you're like a
beautiful pink well this is the one for
my permit okay you BYO seed yeah I don't
love the coffee here Wow free coffee
entitlement of interns these days
it's entitlement of PAS these days yeah
well also I just hadn't finished mine
this morning so I was like why would I
throw it out I'm not gonna be wasteful
so the stories for today some of them
might be like a few days old I just
really wanted to talk about them a lot
titus Burgess first Andy Cohen like I
need to tell you all about it but for
the most part it's it's keeping up with
what's going on some stories have we
weren't able to talk about also please
allow me for the sake of everyone to do
about sorry cap yes and by the way I
watch okay so we have two and I have a
lot of thoughts okay um and I feel like
I literally didn't watch any of the
season I but I watch the finale and I
know everything so for the most part you
know the nitty gritty shitty but it
doesn't matter yeah okay so I'm just
gonna jump right in to some really
exciting news for me the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show is allegedly
canceled and here's what he new x' wants
you to know what it really means for the
brand almost every year since 1995
Victoria's Secret has sent a parade of
models clad in an array of bejeweled
feathered and peekaboo lingerie down a
runway and what ultimately became a
nationally televised event this year the
schedule is bare she Nina shake who
walked in her first Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show in 2011 told The Telegraph
in her native Australia on Tuesday that
there will be no show unfortunately the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show won't be
happening this year it's something I'm
not used to because every year around
this time I'm training like an angel but
I'm sure in the future something will
happen which I'm pretty sure about her
bombshell revelation preceded any
official or unofficial word from the
company and Victoria's Secret has yet to
come fully confirm the news otherwise or
even comment but while this probably
wasn't a part of the plan um Victoria
Secrets
they may now feel as if the world has
walked in on it wearing nothing but its
skivvies oh my god people it is just
like I'm lost at this point an internal
memo circulated in May informing
employees that they were rethinking the
annual Fashion Show first held at the
Plaza in 95 and had concluded that the
network television was no longer the
right fit so they were gonna do it but
they weren't gonna televise it instead
they would work on creating a new kind
of event ABC started airing the show in
2001 and more than twelve million people
tuned in CBS took over the following
year and that's where it remained
through 2017 then it returned to ABC in
2018 and it only netted three million
viewers from 12 that's literally less
than the Bachelorette that's like what
Real Housewives gets of Atlanta that's
insane for the past few months we've
said that we are taking a fresh look at
every aspect of our business
Lex West nor the CEO of Victoria's
Secret's parent company told employees
an MMO from merchandising marketing and
brand positioning to our real estate
portfolio digital business and cost
structure literally everything so I mean
first of all two things one I mean this
is just really proof like of how in this
day and age like your brand suffers if
you don't evolve like okay in 2001
having like skimpy super skinny girls
like pretty much all of them being white
but that could fly in 2001 but it's like
we're more woke now and the fact that
literally every brand in the country
that has been around for a while has
evolved with the time slit or it was
adamant about just like not changing and
this is what happens yeah I'm like I
don't really care I'm not like someone
was like love like victorious but I used
to be like when I was like ooh like a
shrimp always on gyro CEO in America
alphadon was like god Bless America like
me I was I loved it but even now like
I'll only miss it just because I loved
like the back state like with like
Kendall and Gigi were there and you get
like those back there go there now right
but you know what made me just stuck out
the most and that whole article was when
she well two things
hey like why does she need a shake get
she get to be the one with an incident
it was definitely an accident and but
that's why it's so weird or it's like
they didn't want to make it a big deal
like if they made an official
announcement like everyone be talking
about that might basically like pointing
the finger like haha you don't include
us we don't include you think you think
she got in trouble no I think that they
wanted it to be like not such a big deal
to you
even though it's a huge deal right and
second when she was like right now I'd
be training like an angel like how nice
is that that you don't have to be right
now it sounds like you should go on
vacation Chinni yeah I think that
they're all on vacation right now well
and it just makes me think of like the
brands that have come up in the time
that Victoria's Secret kind of like
whittled away like third love which is
like you where only I only wear third
like it's literally the best bras
awfully explore too Illustrated they
kind of became like what Victoria's
Secret should have been yeah like they
were all about like real luscious bodies
I get [ __ ] Ashley Graham on the cover
three years ago like they were so ahead
of their time and they're like bigger
and better than ever and like that's
just proof it's like that's what you get
when you listen to your customers like
agree where the Victoria Secrets are in
this country it's like they're in malls
all around the country they like like
real America like where people don't
look like she Nina shake like yeah or
they don't look like Devon Windsor and
it's like they never they never wanted
to communicate with their real customers
like what fantasy are you living in
nobody [ __ ] looks like that no one's
gonna wear two million dollar bra no
literally I can't tell you the last time
I shopped at Victoria's Secret
great that's the thing and that's what
their big announced it was earlier in
the year that they're gonna close out a
lot of their real estate online I think
they're bringing back to me yeah they
they used to have the cutest swim I used
to go every time I needed bathing suit
is Victoria's Secret and they were so
cute their new swim is some of the
ugliest swam I've ever seen because it's
not theirs
right there now basically like a
Bloomingdale's they're a department
store for other companies to sell their
labels they don't have a computer ones
they don't have a Victoria Secret label
anymore which is what they were so
successful at right women loved and they
were really reasonably priced okay but
fine now you want to take other people's
whatever choose better ones no totally
they're so ugly they're just like the
brand is suffering and their CEO or an
IDI Razik is very much involved in the
Jeffrey Epstein of it all I think it
said raise it or it's someone super high
up so like their name has just been like
being dragged through the mud and it's
like it's not getting better
but it would just be so crazy if
Victoria Secret went out of business
because at one point in time it was the
biggest company in America yeah and it's
also like you could not go into a ball
and not have a Victoria Secret right and
it's also become like a huge avenue for
like people to become models yeah that
it's like then that'll be totally shut
down it's like then it's even harder for
them that's what Sports Illustrated is
doing now k-dubb didn't never heard of
her before she was on the cover how did
Ava
never heard of her before she was on the
cover I mean I heard of Camille Cossack
because if I were an incident like
they're really about like taking smaller
mom like they also have now become like
this filler for for models
ya know we're taking search Chris Reagan
she and Nina Agdal the three of them
Chrissy Teigen was famous before but
like that really blew up that blew up
for Nina Agdal oh yeah they really have
become like a platform for like you to
become a huge model naturally Tracy
because they are the new more woke
millennial sport Victoria Secret yeah
except they don't sell anything besides
magazines make money they should they
should make bikinis they really should
but some of the bikinis that they wear
in the I don't spread unrealistic I
there's one that I'll never be able to
get out of my head like it's Danielle
Harrington in this year's swim and like
it's just it's just string literally
wraps here goes just straight over her
nipple string over here string over a
nipple and then it like goes down as if
it's a one-piece it's literally insane
like it just covers the thing if that is
so I know but like they are really a
great company and I just wanted to and
there's always been a fan of MJ day if
you're watching yeah well I love it like
the girls that they pick on the cover
like have like like honestly like I know
I say this maybe I'm just bitter like I
don't want it like in my dream body it's
not one of the Victoria's Secret doesn't
they look like so like I don't want a
body shame but like you know anything
it's just like no I want to look
seriously like Kate Upton like she has
luscious breasts so I can nice curves
like that is what I want to leave
actually weirdly have this same like
role model body girls yeah like a tough
to know but Devon Bruggeman oh oh my god
I think she should be in motion Monday
swimwear line they do their own fashion
show and everything it might be a
competitor whatever
Devon Bregman we were just talking about
her like oh my god I want her body like
so bad she is literally the most
beautiful skin so tan oh my god she's
the best about it in like the best hits
no literally I get like a dude you see
the jugs on that girl she posted like
she posted her wearing something and she
was like I'm wearing an extra small in
shorts and like a large on top oh like
that's that's what I want I want to be a
large on top and an extra small on
bottom I just I really like I'm I am now
like diving headfirst into being a Stan
of
SI swimsuit culture me dude there's
nothing not to love about them no
they're so inclusive like when they put
Ashley Graham on the cover like it
shouldn't have been such a big deal but
like it really wasn't it was very
innovative and like I was just super
here for it and she looked [ __ ] great
I mean she's like she's beautiful we met
her answer stunning in curling Bay's and
she's like she dressed herself but she
looked so cool like she had a stylist
you know what I mean yeah she's cool I
love her yeah um so I'm just I'm super
here for it um sad that people I guess
are being put out of a job but you know
I just feel like she need a shape will
be fine oh they'll be more than fine
some be more than fine but like this
definitely affects model squad for sure
I wonder if they're gonna talk about it
I didn't even know that they were
bringing it back I don't know I really
hope I loved it I don't think I haven't
heard anything I mean Jackie were the
number one fans of that show I'm
probably the only two viewers but like
it's so good no I just like seeing like
what they were up to all the time and
like where they live and like what their
family but I just like what their days
are like yeah I actually really would
only love it I know she got a reality
show okay this next story was handpicked
by me because I was getting involved in
some conversations on the toast about it
and people had really differing opinions
and I would love to hear your opinion
and I will give you the start to finish
of the whole saga of Titus Burgess for
sandy Cohen I all this is super hard for
me because like I am a tennis and
ramadhan like super fan stand like I've
been posting about him like for years I
think he's like one of the most
underrated characters in all of
television but any Cohen is like my
father like I drink I live breathe a
diaphragm and we mention the John Mayer
concert be a bit of the chosen so long
song oh my god oh my god I know okay we
went to the John Mayer concert and it
was absolutely unbelievable
The Guardian hooked us up with tickets
and we were backstage and we just were
in this leg room with such good snacks
and and he was just sitting there and I
just like we were just like friends of
Andy like I don't wanna be annoying like
he was just who they were having a good
time and like I would didn't want to
like bother him but I have to know when
to be a fan and when to be cool yeah and
we had to be going to be cool but I just
like was really just like really humbled
and honored to be in his presence like I
really look up to him so much okay so I
don't want to read the recap because I
actually know full full well what
happened okay I really I read the only
thing I read about it was his comment
okay so Titus was on watch repins live
with Laverne Cox and it was such great
episode they both are housewives fans
they both have new stuff coming out he
was there promoting because new
on album and the new single and and II
like had had done in T's like what he
knew and he knew what was going on he
was the upper Moni he said he had
listened to the song that he it sounded
like a real upbeat Bop like he was
trying he was trying but it's like he
had done his research on the person okay
this show was definitely more Luverne
heavy because she was in the first chair
she is like such a megastar the new
season emerges a new black I know you
didn't watch it but I you have to watch
it okay I rarely tell me to watch things
so I don't like the ending for Piper but
the whole show and you know what I
really don't like when things are
political but it was like such an
important political message Margo it was
it was so good like I it was amazing and
justice for that woman who don't a yeah
who I forget her name I think her name
was Carla like justice for her Blancas
friend like okay I'm done I'm done so
and I by the way I just I want to add my
personal experience when I was an intern
at AOL Titus had come in and my job was
to go in to the greenroom of celebrities
and I have them filmed something for our
social media so I was based it was a
season one Kimmy Schmidt and I was like
please just like do a quick clip being
like hi I'm Titus Burgess Pino and like
I don't know I guess you just assumed
that like the person that they play on
TV is like who they are right he's so
good at being Titus and Ramadan that
like I didn't think he would be anything
other than like super out there and he
was like kind of rude to me he was like
no and it was just super awkward I was
like an intern I just remember him being
like a little rude especially because he
had just kind of like popped up on the
scene yeah and I was like oh that's
interesting whatever so this whole this
whole interaction didn't really surprise
me and Laverne was there just like
having the best time just being like
truly a goddess and like everyone who
called in and Andy like they just had
like so much respect for and it was like
really nice to just like watch and I
could feel Titus like wasn't like
feeling the show so much and he started
to get a little annoyed when he was
talking about a project a play he wrote
a long time ago that he's trying to get
off the ground he might have found a
producer and it's like a rewrite of some
well-known show I don't know the exact
specifics and Andy was like oh my god I
didn't know that you had written that
that's amazing and tennis was like oh I
told you that you know a million times
and he was kind of insinuating that
basically like Andy
care about him okay enough to do
research on it but it's like he wasn't
there promoting that play right he was
promoting his album which and he had
spoken to and and seems like he knew a
lot about so Tidus was just like so
offended that Andy didn't remember to
Jimmy guess and he has on his show like
every day who tell him a million things
like no like it was he just took offense
that and like that really turned him off
but then someone called in and asked
what it was like for him to shoot this
movie that is coming out soon it with
Eddie Murphy okay and I don't know the
specifics because I wasn't around when
Eddie Murphy was starting up and doing
stand-up but I read in his book and
there's a moment in it that literally
made me cry it was so sad and he was
like really struggling with his identity
and he was knew he was gay he hadn't
come out yet and him and his friends
went to go see Eddie Murphy stand up
okay and there was a ton of jokes that
were like super homophobic and
transphobic and and he went to the
bathroom and literally hysterically
cried the whole show and never went back
and it was like it's as part of this
show that is like I mean it's part of
the book that like I actually remember I
remember nothing like yeah I remember
that because it was like so sad so it's
obviously like Eddie Murphy has this
trigger for Andy Cohen and Titus is gay
and and he was like you know what was
that like you know he wasn't so great
for the gay community back in the day
and tie this was not [ __ ] here for
that question he was just like come on
Letitia like move on like he was a
junior show and he was like making faces
he didn't know the camera was on him and
he was like looking at someone the
audience was like he was so awkward like
and he was any really ask a question
innocently
and I thought maybe Titus would have
some more to say about it yeah and
Laverne was just like me it was so
awkward yeah yeah it was like it was so
awkward and like I really felt the whole
time and maybe I'm just biased because I
really loved Andy but I really felt the
whole time he was trying really hard to
Titus even acted kind it's made it so
weird yeah oh and then they go to
commercial break and like usually you
just sit while the camera pans out Titus
got up and went somewhere like before
the camera had even turned off oh my god
so awkward and he was visibly upset he
wheeled it back in but I felt like and
he was trying super hard with him like
to make him feel included just because I
think sometimes I'm not trapped inside
like when like Laverne is like so like
oranges new back is am I
Big Show and she is like really a
transcendent fixture in Hollywood and I
just think like he was trying really
hard to make Titus feel included and
then the Titus went on his Instagram and
responded to a comment about Andy and it
was it was real okay
I'm gonna find the whole thing give me a
second okay I mean I know but people in
the toast were just being like and maybe
maybe I was saying like maybe I'm just
missing that because I'm such an Andy
Sam but they were just like he it was so
obvious that he like wanted nothing to
do with it like he didn't care about
Titus he didn't do any research on him
before coming on his show that's what
people in the shows were saying yeah but
people were divided truly okay I'm
trying to find the comment but I'll just
read it but they like they cut it all up
on BuzzFeed okay
tennis Burgess best known for his role
as Thai descent ramen and called out
television host and producer Andy Cohen
for being a messy Queen he should
remember his talk show isn't an episode
of The Real Housewives of Atlanta it's a
place where artists come to talk about
art and have a little fun not a place to
track rehash old rumors or bring a star
to negative press I just want to say
that's exactly what it is that's exactly
okay it's like a very tabloid II type of
yeah he didn't do his research and he
also said he was making it very
confusing being like I am NOT Who I am
and he was like I have won four Emmys
for being someone other than myself but
you don't see me as myself it was so
confusing and I wasn't understanding but
basically it was like you could take a
note being friends with talented
celebrities doesn't make you a talented
celebrity which is so mean and he was
like you could take a lesson out of
Anderson Cooper and learn how to do your
job oh yeah I saw that you like to
different than I is hitting two hosts
against each other they're like best
friends so do your research no it was so
weird um Andy Cohen hid the question he
asked was I was just wondering if you
got close at all because he was very
problematic for the gays at one point
that was a question that said time is
off and try to said oh I see he wasn't
problematic for Titus we had a wonderful
time we talked about Dreamgirls he
should have won the Oscar I believe
Burgess added any troubles Murphy may
have had with gay people in the past
must be gone because he loved me and
actually as I'm reading it now it sounds
like a normal like actually a good
response but in the moment he was like
you can't you can't
the attitude he had like you know what's
you um the actor was later seen making a
face on camera suggested he didn't
approve of Andy's Coen I'm Andy's
question and then Annie was responding
to a few things on Twitter just seeing
like he really thought it was a fair
question
um and he obviously didn't expect for it
to like become this whole hoopla but I
was just really torn about it because
everyone seemed to be on different pages
in me and I feel like I'm some I'm I try
and see the whole I mean it's so hard
when we were apologists for the people
that we love
right and you can do not wrong but like
sometimes she doesn't I don't really see
that Andy did anything wrong like I mean
I didn't watch it so I can't speak to
their behavior body language and
attitude but from what you're saying it
just seems as though Titus is a little
bit of a diva and yeah he's giving me
deeper vibes yeah the way he acted to
you
season one so imagine how much worse it
is now so these are some comments I just
want to read because I wouldn't want to
know where the world stands on this
because I know it's like not a big deal
in the grand scheme of the world but
like to me this is a big deal I find
that I'm always on the opposite side of
the world and he had every right to ask
Titus those questions it's his show and
as a gay man he wanted an explanation
that's what someone said all Titus had
to say was Eddie has transformed and now
supports the gay community yeah that's
what Sally he they said he got up to
talk to the bartender at the end of the
show Titus personally only talked to
Laverne so that Andy was sitting there
by himself Melissa says Titus took it
personally no that's me yeah I just um
this is what Hannah Lewis said I think
it was his behavior after he answered
the question when he looked at someone
off screen and mouth that was
off-putting that's what he said but why
like it's just it's a normal question
right and just answer it like you don't
have to like to say like a whole thing
just be like he was fun he literally
could have just said he was fine to me
Spencer Lynn said I can admit when Andy
gets very pod story but this was
uncalled for
yeah it's definitely known I mean his
show it she just recalled the
pot-stirrer and Andy says he's like I'm
the only gay in late-night like I have
to do it I have to be my most you know
extra self right and I love that about
him and that's what I think who draws a
lot of people to the show
so then um titus Burgess also went on
Wendy Williams and spoke about it I mean
this is it's just I I found myself
disagreeing with so many people and I
couldn't tell if I was just being like
an Andy Cohen Savior apologist but I
from personal experience like Titus was
super rude to me like as an intern like
I never dozen yeah but that was season
one anything in the grand scheme of the
world but like the attitude he was
having on the show up just like the
superiority definitely felt familiar to
me ya know he which is so sad because
like Titus and Ramadan the character
like to me is one of the most well
written hysterical to watch Kim shrimp
yeah I haven't like everything that
comes out of his mouth is genius and I
guess you just associate that must be
annoying like as an actor like when
people just assume you are who you are
on television I mean it is so hard for
me to disassociate a character from a
human especially when the act is so good
like Titus purchase is so good at acting
that I cannot even think that he's
anything other than Titus and Ramadan
yeah but it's like they're not right so
he must be such a good actor yeah yeah
that's true right
sad sad I hate to see you now another
song now oh the archer I can't believe
we didn't do a show since the archer
right now I mean I love that she just
dropped it on a Tuesday at 5 o'clock and
did it make us wait for it like usually
they'll do a live stream you like it's
coming on Friday it's like four days
just waiting for Easter eggs it's good
you know it's definitely the direction I
want her music to be moving to so I'm
really glad about that
I do wish the beat dropped like the
whole song being an up build I get the
metaphor of it it's like I just I needed
the beach a job I mean I get that but
like I understand that you're saying
then but I was like listening to it
yesterday it was like morning I was just
like tired and it came on and I was just
and it was just like it felt like a hug
like it's just like such a good song it
just makes you feel good even though I
don't think it's really supposed to I
don't know it's like every time I listen
to it I like it more and more which i
think is a good thing me to actually say
me and I'm just happy like we're moving
more towards like a softer more acoustic
like less reputation by because
reputation was great it's just not my
attic I was headed for Taylor like
listening to her three new songs that
have come out because I've been
listening to my spot if I play this
called t-swift catalog it's just all of
her songs and collabs in one playlist
and so like they're intermittent with
those and like I can see these songs
like being like well like talking a talk
about them in like five years
so good like now it's like you never
know how good you have it till it's gone
type of thing so it's like I feel like a
few years having lied over the cloud
those were so good like me like I think
me is a banger me is great everyone like
when it first came out everyone was like
no this ain't Halley yeah great big you
can't ask me whatever I mean it's a
great lead single like it's very 22
we're never getting back together like
it's my favorite song no but is it a
banger yes yeah it's one of those songs
we listened to it enough like you'll
start to hate it like we're not going to
okay so she announced yesterday that she
unjam a she's gonna be doing a show in a
freak show in Central Park
I mean shows in Central Park are so
treacherous and there's always some sort
of threat like global citizens that's
the last year they had to evacuate it
like there's always some sort of scary
threat but like and for like I can't
even imagine what its gonna be like for
Taylor I wonder how they're gonna like
you could just show up are there tickets
I don't know
and they're smart I don't know there has
been a lot of information on like actual
logistics is it like one of those things
you like wake up before I am I'm having
me and Myra Sahara cells in the Today
Show and like it was amazing but like I
don't know if it was worth waking up at
4:00 a.m. I mean who's only worth waking
up before I am because you saw it twice
because if you take now her soul like a
full show yeah and then he also did the
televised version so you were there
forever but you got to she actually
shows but I don't think I would I don't
I don't think it's worth it like also
cuz after a prime day like where we got
we got the best of the best like it's
not gonna be that she's singing new
songs but I really don't think she's
getting to sing new songs it's a day
before I don't think I could ever like
go to another Taylor Swift concert
because prime day was so [ __ ]
premium like we had a lot to be the
table we had like a waitress like that
was and we were so close to her like I
don't think I could ever go to another
show like I've officially been spoiled I
know but like what we're gonna go what's
in a laboratory um of course we're going
to the leper tour and also like a toast
of the lovers in my song yeah I know it
wasn't intentional but like be Sharon
maybe it was you Sharon
before we move on to the next story
which I picked specifically for you I
would be absolutely remiss if I didn't
let everyone know that today's episode
is brought to you by candid Co did you
know your teeth move as you get older
and if you want to get your teeth fix
the last thing you want to do is wear
braces that's why we're happy to tell
you about candy Co the clear alternative
to braces candy does an orthodontist who
is licensed in your state create a
treatment plan for you and can the co
only uses experienced dontist they
create a 3d preview of what the final
results are going to be like once you
approve that preview they create
some clear aligner that we sent directly
to you that means no hassle of having to
go into an office can the co costs 65%
less than braces you can save thousands
of dollars and have straighter brighter
teeth an average of just six months
you're one step away from getting
straight or brighter teeth
learn more at candid koat.com slash
toast
use code toast to get $75 off that's a
great price
that's Canada koat.com slash toast code
toast for $75 off I know a bunch of
people who have used I really know that
I feel my bottom teeth moving I know
that you know what me too
cuz we didn't have braces I know but
it's really like so nice when you were
in middle school like an you got brace
it's like your life was absolutely over
but I just love companies like candy co
that like you no longer have to ruin
like your social life yeah like you
never now you do have to be like a metal
brace face yeah no I remember that show
brace face yeah of course like that's
how much I would have brace like hat on
you would get your braces off and take
you to upload that stuff you know and it
was literally like the biggest deal
looks like your BOTS mates are getting
your braces yeah but it's implanted
koat.com slash tous and use code tous
for $75 off actually I might do that
I'm Oh cuz I feel like if they're moving
now I'm 22 you can prevent it where am I
gonna be in tension that's a great great
great way to thank God the way someone
said that GM a said a cheese singing new
songs and dropping a single that day a
single right before the album I don't
know interesting in terrace on okay this
next story is picked specifically
specifically for you it's a new
development in an ongoing story that I
know you're heavily involved in Cole
Sprouse reveals his first kiss happened
in the back of a hearse with a girl
named Charlene but he fails to discuss
his rumored split from co-star
girlfriend okay so I'm just kidding can
I give her a rundown I don't feel I know
but I tell you about what he didn't hear
me about his first kiss do you know what
a hearse is yeah of course it's where
dead bodies go yeah okay he to Vol'jin
details of a strange date that led to a
memorable first kiss the revelation came
comes after the Riverdale star neither
confirmed nor denied that he has split
from his girlfriend Lili Reinhardt the
pair were photographed on the cover of
w-wait I want to hear more about the
hearse Charlene was her name strange
name as well her father was an offbeat
man he was an avid Hot Wheels collector
but then he also owned a hearse and he
was part of the Hearst Club which is
probably where my dark sense of humor
comes from okay so I'm think there was a
dead body I think they were just like
chillin in there in her dad's hearse
yeah for sure that is hilarious but
honestly that's like so on brand that
like okay you need me to run down I
don't really know what's happening they
were like rumors that they broke up
everyone confirmed it that's true and
then they came out with this article so
here's an upset I'll say the facts and
then I'll say what I think is happening
/ happened so basically all of a sudden
we see Us Weekly posted that they broke
up and they were just I had been at
comic-con literally the weekend prior
and this was like maybe Monday or
Tuesday there would be like super cute
and like normal as they always are at
these things one can argue it's business
and they had to act professional
whatever they are actors yeah they are
actors whatever so this came out it was
like not really based off anything like
a source said that they overheard Cole
saying that they broke up but it's like
why is that source like the most trusted
person on the planet right so much so
that he news but reporting yes so that
everyone started to pick it up and every
was like they're broken up they're
broken up in the sand um the fan
accounts I follow like we're losing
their minds like they were like you know
this is not true this is not true and I
would ever at first I was like this is
not true like they were just so cute at
whatever it's like they are so private
like I really don't know that it would
be like this way I don't know it felt
weird the whole thing felt weird so then
as we saw they came out with the W cover
where like they look like vampires or
some [ __ ] they look great though he
looks so look sometimes I think he's so
hot and sometimes I think he looks dirty
who do you think is hotter Dylan or Cole
Dylan
michio but it's like and by the way
tilling was made even hotter for me the
fact that he's in like such a great
healthy relationship my god it's the
most amazing picture me like I made that
by like you would think that he's a
girlfriend like whatever like no I think
that makes him more attractive me too
and like they're twins yes okay so they
posted the cover Lily Robert posted it
and she goes breaking a reliable source
has confirmed that none of you know [ __ ]
basically implying that they are not
broken up right and then : scrammed it
as well and he said I just wouldn't get
my you know back straight he said
unprecedented : Cole Sprouse and Lilly
Reinhart consumed the flesh of reliable
sources to fuel their but Choi own alien
sex cult whatever there's some weird
Cole Sprouse thing captions most happen
to like you were together in this rumor
but the article keeps referring to them
as a couple that has now split and but
the article also kind of didn't really
make sense like I don't know it was it
was like was this guy just going based
off fact or his assumption that now
after
stuff has come up they they are broken
up so he rewrote the article a day
before what's so weird is that this
article and their Instagram posts were
meant to clarify exactly what was going
on but they made it so confusing that
even now I don't know are they together
both of their nap like the narratives
are different the writers and their so
what's interesting is that when they
both posted this they tagged every
single person involved in the confer
story except for the writer which makes
me think that they do not approve of
this of the article okay then why
wouldn't why would they just not post
about it because I'm sure they have to
contractually okay so then anyway and
then Cole Sprouse Instagram bien said an
incredible pleasure to work again with
intact everybody except for the writer
and obviously you think you it's an
article you can tag the writer an
incredible pleasure to shake all of your
beliefs in tabloid media implying that
there's it's not it's a tabloid it's not
true it's incredibly confusing and they
this was a really poorly
you know arranged PR moment because
obviously there were a bunch of people
like the magazine their publicists the
talent like all kind of orchestrating to
announce something but I have no idea
what they announce are they together or
are they not in your bow then Lilly
Reinhardt tweeted don't believe
everything you read on the internet kids
and news sources to try a little harder
to be less file reliable sources can
kiss my ass
and then she replied to Cosmo did like
article called Milliron heart just like
the shadiest video of cole sprouse at
comic-con and she replied and said or i
liked you because it's a funny video of
me not wanted to talk with a cookie in
my mouth so they're like I think this is
what I think happened I think that they
did break up at the beginning of the
summer I think they were back together
now so I think that they're like being
this defensive way because they're
together now and it doesn't matter
whereas if they were actually broken up
they wouldn't be doing any of this
because they're both constantly like in
each other's photos like he posted
something I want a.m. last night and 10
minutes later she would she liked it so
like I think they are together now but I
do think that they did break up for a
little brief stint I honestly have no
idea but I think that I mean based on
what they're saying everything they've
put out and they're trying to make it
seem like they are still together but
everyone around them in the article it
feels like go who would know better than
the journalist you know what I mean well
the journalists didn't like when when he
interview them they were together so
like what do you mean how would he know
that two months later they're gonna
break up if they even did I have
no idea the whole thing made though
article was so weird like babies are
really poorly orchestrated like PR
moment because the public is more
confused than ever and then he ended the
article with but all is good wink-wink
so is the whole is a whole article
satire a satirical I have no idea it's
so weird
no I think they're together now there's
definitely something happening prior to
that but they are together if they're
not together like how does that affect
the franchise you think I don't know
because it's like it depends how
professional they can be because if it
doesn't really that they just like our
professional actors blah blah blah I
mean I'm sure that bug head would break
up in the show they would have to so
sake of like anyway with your anyways
you get like a barchi moment which like
honestly I'm I'm there I have been a bar
cheese Sam like since the beginning and
I was very much here for VAR t because
they were cute but like it's Betty and
Archie like it's always been Betty and
RJ who won in the know it never ended oh
because didn't like actually I'm not
gonna spoil it if anyone's still reading
Archie comics ya know but they never
like he was one day with Archie he was
with Veronica yeah so he's just yeah but
it was like the nice all-american girl
yeah jess is for Betty so hopefully like
writer Ross can keep everyone in line
and just like hope because there's
nothing worse than like we see this all
the time I'm like a hit show brings
itself down hmm
self-destructive totally yeah what other
shows have been kind of like that
we're like the the people like won't
even film together Oh like I think that
happened with like um Vampire Diaries
remember remember oh yeah there was that
whole love triangle yeah
and Shh what else I don't know I feel
like probably one tree no I never
watched it but me neither but that does
suck like when this is the show is like
in its early years has so much potential
and it gets brought down by like stupid
drama that's why they always say you
shouldn't date your coworkers literally
like Mark Consuelos state and podcast
with Andy Cohen when this whole thing
came out and he like asked and he was
like I don't know if he was acting but
mark was like oh my god they did I
hadn't heard though he's like I've been
in Vancouver for the past week I love
her you have a phone I love how Andy
Cohen like is somehow linked to pretty
much everything that goes on the world
read like he was in an episode of River
Ellen like for that he is my daddy
Oh also this is definitely not a story
but they're casting a third crystal
Indian dynasty how stupid it's like just
kill her off I think maybe at this point
it's supposed to be like a joke like
every season he gets an
like didn't they do don't they do that
like soap operas yeah I think that I got
a new face pops up I think it's like now
a joke that's really annoying cousin
Cara because with the crystal and like
storyline like never really I don't care
like I am Fallon or bust
yeah me too it like I don't care about
anybody else I'm Rider die Fallon
Carrington I also sorry I
everything's just coming back to me yeah
dude she's over 101 reunion thing yes
okay well did you see that they posted
like with Dan Schneider thanking him no
but he was in one of the photos he was
there he set it up and then and then and
then he posted it to like literally
Victoria Jessica wrote thank you at blah
blah blah for setting this up and he was
there but then there's that other girl
who I think played Quinn Quinn was there
oh no then she played Lauren was telling
us someone named Nicole yeah I forget
who she played but she was like one of
the main girls she wasn't invited and
she's been very vocal on her Instagram
story so like Dan as a predator he's a
part of like the Nickelodeon Tori crew
and she's like has a million Instagram
stories of her crying because she wasn't
invited and because Dan was there but
why would she want to be many of Tammuz
there right I don't know it's very
confusing like this whole thing because
in my mind like obviously Dan Schneider
is an animal yeah it's like why would
all these kids who are now I'm grown up
and haven't seen him in ten years like
why would they go I don't know I don't
know but there's no way that it's not
true it's very confusing I don't know
okay should we jump into the next story
they just brought up three yes
Oh anyway so yeah : Lily I think as of
right now are back on track
that's my opinion okay next up is some
real internet news Oh Jake Paul and tan
emotional oh I can't to those you know
that okay so they got married allegedly
um and they paid they live streamed it
and charge people $50 you see that the
morning tube like he donated like one
cents so that they could like stream it
in the thing and but didn't want at all
pay for why I mean before I even tell
you about the actual story like the fact
that they got married is so funny I mean
obviously this is like some elaborate PR
stunt do I think they're in love no I
think that there's gonna be like a big
announcement or something that they
break up know like that they're
promoting something oh oh oh like a new
fragrance I don't [ __ ] know but like
this is not real no I but so apparent
there was a big like fluke with their
live stream to those who paid to watch
the wedding of the YouTube stars at Jake
paulandhannah muzu they were frustrated
with the quality
now or forever miss out on your refund
in case you missed it the couple got
married in Vegas on Sunday and eccentric
ceremony attended by family friends fans
and complete strangers and they live
streamed the event for some reason
despite doubts that the couple's
authenticity is real and sheiks own
brother Logan predicted they'll be only
last a month 66,000 people paid
somewhere between fifty and seventy five
dollars to watch live as the couple said
I do by the way it started late only
lasted ten minutes but those are the
good reviews wait what is sixty six
thousand times $60 Leah bout to do that
between fifty and seventy five so we'll
do a median of $60 sixty six thousand
times sixty yeah what did you write this
is 3.9 million yeah that sounds right
holy [ __ ] wait actually do it again
sixty-six thousand times sixty three
point nine six Wow good for them but
everyone's getting refunds now so not
really oh right so those who shells out
the cash to the streaming app called
halogen complain that the video is shaky
lagging froze often in the audio sucked
many of course demanded refunds and
we've learned they are getting them
teams learned both Apple and Google Play
are paying customers back who purchased
a halogen app through the company's App
Store and bought the livestream halogen
wouldn't tell us that they're
compensating Google and Apple for the
refunds a rep for the company would only
say many high-profile creators use
halogen to broadcasts or live events
sometimes on site technical issues with
third party production providers used by
creators can cause fans to experience
issues while live streaming by the way
Jake and tannaz so-called wedding came
just a little over a month after they
got engaged and just days after she
pulled the pregnancy prank after the
ceremony
a fight that looked awfully set up broke
out shortly after the officiant
pronounced them husband and wife
the officiant also referred to their
glorious day as a gathering in the holy
club Trump cloud Rimini cloud Rimini
matrimony cloud o chasers hard to
imagine why anyone would question their
you did oh there's also no record of
them filing a marriage license in Clark
County
at least viewers get refunds anyone who
bought a wedding gift good luck so I'm
very curious if the app is gonna be
refunding people or if Apple and Google
are we funding people on their behalf
but I have to imagine that the app is
gonna be helping out of all oh for sure
because it kind of is that AB small I
just can't wait till we find out like
what the end of this is like obviously
this isn't real it's there's a bigger
more strategic plan here what is it and
did you see that she like posted an
Instagram
today and she was like um what she said
this will probably it was so weird like
she were the whole thing's talking about
how much she loves him like whatever and
how like I know they're soul mates or
some [ __ ] they're so weird and she wrote
I'm probably gonna be posting wedding
photos longer than we're married
lol you know what they're like this
generations like Britney who did Britton
get married to in Vegas for 72 hours
Jason Alexander you know what I mean
like remember when like people just like
get married for five minutes and like
Britney Spears and they don't know it
yeah like they are really like the Gen
Z's like Britney Spears yeah she doesn't
sing but you know what I mean yeah
she has a show on MTV now I doing one I
saw her on a billboard she's the host of
some show Britney Spears no tanamashu
who where did she come from
I have literally no idea actually I do
know she really uh got her start she was
Bella Thorne's like besties and I think
they day they do and that was the first
time actually so yeah it actually heard
of her from you know my snack Daily Mail
right Hannah monkey this is just so
weird I'm like this the scent has gone
on long enough I want to know what
they're from I think everyone's over it
also they're losing a lot of interest
yeah and they're losing money now
because they have to refund all these
people sad um okay final story it's one
obviously a hand-picked for you also but
I did watch The Bachelorette finale
okay um The Bachelorette Jed White's ex
response to Hannah Browns message to her
whatever I don't really want to get into
it cuz I don't really care about his
girlfriend um what are your thoughts
so the finale happened and basically she
picked Jed she sent Tyler C home and
then I don't know how much time later
but they've obviously figured out that
Jed was like two weeks he admitted to
having a girlfriend being in love going
on the show purely for press for his
music but he said that no he said it
wasn't his girlfriend yet they wouldn't
broke up with her in his heart parents
he broke up with her in his heart and
like he didn't even say that they were
exclusive he broke up with her in his
heart yeah it's like it's like you just
decide in your head we're broken up this
is how it works bro you gotta tell the
other I'm gonna get on two dates with
someone but you go on a trip to the
hummus with her family the whole thing
and you met each other's parents you're
not dating we don't even beyond that
like Jed was so not the guy for her Oh
100%
like so well I understand her being
frustrated at the fact like basically
this whole season was a waste for her
and like this was a great opportunity
for her to meet someone and she did it
because he ended up being a piece of
[ __ ] regardless of the boyfriend stuff
like he was not the guy for her and I
think that like she is also a little bit
like she should be regretting obviously
she chose the wrong guy cuz he's an
[ __ ] but like he also wasn't the
right guy even beyond all that stuff
yeah the gems that she had like the fact
that there's three hardcore contenders
for bachelor is so crazy there's usually
one maybe two but like Mike Peter and
Tyler like everything like if any of
them get it the world will be excited
exactly there's no good guys and like
the fact that she chose the bad one like
I know I mean here's the thing like I
like you didn't watch the whole season
but I loved her like she really is one
of the greatest I treasure these such
great things and I love her too it was
that she was outspoken about just like
having sex with whoever and wherever but
loved when did you have sex with in the
way Mel Peter four times so what did she
go with Peter I don't know I have no
idea and I I think that Peter was really
the one for her like absolutely like as
much they loved time to see he's so hot
he's great whatever they're nothing he
actually did end up going on the date
with gigi hadid I heard that you do but
you grease no like not now but since
this show has been on there's no that's
what I heard
but I can I don't know if that's true I
kind of wanna call [ __ ] on that I
just don't see that I'm kind of here for
it got really a good-looking couple he
should be a model you know I don't know
was he doing the modeling vote like it
said general contractor he should be a
model he's really [ __ ] like handsome
and interesting looking
he does like like these like charity
runs or something he does charity I
don't know I can't keep up but um I
think she made the mistake by not
choosing Peter but like yes like
everyone's like she has terrible
judgment like well like okay she made
some bad choices like I just feel bad
for her I think that like yes we shade
the whole press day that everyone always
has imagine like she was alone doing
that like with the person you won with
or whatever you know I never forget the
paparazzi pictures of Shawn and Caitlin
after they finally got to announce that
he was the winner because like I feel
like they had a really hard time being
apart from each other because I know
they're not together anymore but I feel
like that was like a real they really
look like a strong relationship and
those paparazzi pictures of them just
like walking around New York like just
being so and
like I literally remember them like that
must be the most happy like freeing time
and she's doing it alone and it is
really it just like makes me sad now and
it's like I can like see the sad in her
eyes it's like I can see the dead in her
eyes also because like between you and I
like her and Tyler's here never getting
a drink like he's a megastar now ggot
follows him on Instagram like everyone
the world's in love with him and like
what like didn't even they were just
talking about it like a matter of fact
like Tyler she like of course I'll be
your second choice like yeah Tyler see
is nobody second choice like and they I
think they just wanted the episode to
end because honestly you should have
been like honestly I'm buttered by even
I don't want to be a consolation I think
that they just like wanted to somewhat
give America a happy ending a little bit
of hope so like they probably asked both
parties to do that just to like give
someone give us something to like hold
on to I don't think yeah I know I think
if any ties rise beyond he's America's
Sweetheart oh yeah I think if she should
try and get back together with Peter
like I really think her and Peter are
meant for each other and I don't sleep
on like paradise no definitely not but
like now everyone's saying they want her
to be back to right again and she got
asked that question and she was like um
like I can't even get past where the
[ __ ] I am right now right let me let me
live but I was watching her interviews
and she didn't interview dnews and like
I don't know they never showed who the
interviewer was I would love to know
because in one of her questions she was
like how do you feel about like like
what if Tyler became the bachelor and
like now that Gigi is following him like
literally brought it up and I was just
like watching what she said she didn't
really harp on that at all she just
spoke about how she would be able to
tell her Tyler was a bachelor and I was
just like trying to watch her face and
just to be like that's so sad like
you're like now you're in competition
with Gigi Hadid
that's not fair nobody deserves that
nobody's there and I'm really loving how
like into the franchise Demi Lovato is
and how she was sitting next to Demi
Burnett at the final Rose whose
Instagram is Jaime not Lovato no I agree
and also like she was backstage hanging
out Hannah like buh-bye that has met her
mom I just want to know why I feel like
Demi is not gonna come out to show on
ABC soon and like that's probably oh you
saying like what why who she's gonna be
like the judge on a singing show yeah
maybe sayin like she needs because she
like in her Instagram with Demi Lovato
it Hannah she wrote tune into a boxer at
ABC like I bet you she's getting oh that
sends promoted as [ __ ] yeah there's a
reason
interesting that's just my take but
anyway um [ __ ] Jenn is this the first
time someone has not it has ended up
alone yeah Juan Pablo
oh yeah but like in a long time and
bachelorette that ended up alone yeah
yeah so sad so sad and like she is just
like I love her so much he's just a
beautiful her conversation with Jed was
like really frustrating because it was
going on forever when they were like in
that apartment I don't know where they
were and it was so boring cuz like
neither of them were saying anything and
he was saying the most ludicrous like
stupid outrageous things and like she
wasn't even responding and the point
that I wished she drove home more was
the fact that like being the
Bachelorette is a once-in-a-lifetime
experience like so generally girls I
know like would literally die the
opportunity to be able to take off work
for three months focus on finding a
husband and have 30 guys like dying to
like it's such a special it really isn't
like so many people have found love that
way and it's like it's such a
once-in-a-lifetime lucky fortunate
experience and like now it's trash and
like she wasted it she chose this idiot
and like I wish she kind of harps on
that more just being like you literally
ruined the most special opportunity like
you took advantage of me like you made
me look stupid but like I will never be
able to do this again like yeah it was
literally a once in a lifetime chance
that you took a big massive diary on
like I wish she said that way now I mean
she did say that like she wasn't strict
enough with him yeah he was saying like
I broke up with her in my heart and she
was just like okay you know what does
that mean no she didn't know he's in it
and she was like what like no sheshe
wasn't hard enough on him I guess but
you also do have to remember as shitty
is what he did is and whatever like she
really loved him so it really was
beautiful beautiful ring is the ring
that that kufran got from Ari I know and
Pinocchio it got from they need to
retire later because it's clearly not
recirculate rings I can't it makes so
much sense it's just kind of crazy like
I think when Robbie Hayes proposed to a
man running his proposed to Jo Jo it was
the same ring that someone else like
this is not the first time that someone
has realized the Rings are recycled yeah
no not at all I just like she had her
ring and if you were on that shirt like
would you drink no you were the
Bachelorette if I was the bastard looks
like a lot of camera time a lot of long
days sitting in Glan like would you
drink I always think about um because
it's only that makes it bearable but you
don't to be like slow going
right no I don't think I'd be like I
probably be drinking like wine like I
don't think I do pack your brew mate I
don't think I'd have a sip of tequila oh
for sure I would need a brew made
hardcore yeah keep it keep it cold cuz
don't you just love warm alcohol no well
neither did Dylan who's the founder of
roommate that's why you mean brew mates
mission to shake
the beverage industry for the better
roommates stylish insulated drink ware
is designed to keep your favorite
beverages ice-cold all day long whatever
you take beer wine spirits brew mate is
making sure to make every sip the
perfect temperature
they actually make really cute ones -
jack is like a pastel pink one mine
stainless steel but really just a great
something like you didn't know that you
needed and then I was like we're so into
drinking beer and every time we get beer
we're like we I mean this is something
that obviously the world knows but every
time we get to the bottom ever were like
oh this is gross and you get a fresh one
and it's cold and it's so much better
but it's like I can't drink beer that
fast sober wait it's actually perfect
for beer I know you've been using it for
wine but now I'm thinking beer beer
don't sell it for warm alcohol chill out
with your favorite drinks all day long
with brew mate mrs. brunette calm an ad
code morning to get 15% off your first
order that's 15% off your first order
when you go to brew mate be are you and
a te dot-com and add to code
morning it's really proving out I have
to actually and it's just why you know
us tipsy toasters we deserve more than
warm alcohol no no longer 2019 it's not
necessary so now the girl who was Jed's
girlfriend it's like famous of course
and she's also a musician is she she
went on the Bobby bone show yeah because
like she's in national you know trying
to make him you know what honestly like
I'm I support this girl like [ __ ]
blowing up his spot she didn't even know
what she was doing like what she said
and then like the poor girl who tried to
do the same thing to Peter and it's like
that she broke up in December like
there's absolutely by right here but
like and she this girl had receipts she
had a [ __ ] letter on a napkin like
she it's almost like she planned to know
and it's also just like it's shocking
how like what's word meta okay what are
you trying to say like how like it was a
whole story here like in like wallows
airing every was like freaking a
freaking out it's like literally led to
the relationship ending right because of
like joining me and this has happened
before where people will come and be
like I would say to him but it's never
gotten to the point where it's made it
to after the final rose or ever had a
real impact on the storyline this is the
first time that one of those like Us
Weekly [ __ ] things like actually
impacted what happened on the show no
100% cuz I can you'll always hang here
random so
except at 8 usually never the winner so
it doesn't really matter right at that
point maybe it comes up I meant it all
but it's like usually like not that bad
that it's like they stay together like
the remember Jourdan and Jojo like
everyone's like coming for Jordan and I
don't remember why but there was like a
whole thing well it was it was odd that
he was estranged from his family so yeah
yeah yeah and he was in that but like
there was weird family stuff the fact
that he like had tried to make it as a
an athlete was weird but now Colton did
that too so it's like it's not that
weird but there was just a lot of things
about him that just like screamed cloud
chaser but it actually seems like I like
I will admit I think I was wrong about
them yeah you were and I never was
because I always believed in them and I
love them and they are getting there I
feel like we are on the verge of like a
ton of bachelor weddings
I think Rachel and Brian are gonna be
getting married relatively soon Raven
and Nicole Raven to Colgate so Raven and
Adam Jordan Jojo yes they set a date
it's happening Ashlee I mean oh wow when
it rains it pours because I feel like
their hands made a wedding for a really
long time the last one was like Carly
and evident in our days Lauren and Arie
in January Oh actually their wedding was
so beautiful Twilight I love them so
much like I really am like a believer in
their love and like I love their family
and like I resumed they do an ad I'm
like yes girl make money put into
[ __ ] college fund fertile se because
she deserves to go to an Ivy League
[ __ ] school okay I don't know I'm so
with you every time they post like I
love them it's like I'm sorry like
they're they're really the most legit
out of anybody and I find their ads to
be so helpful like as just like someone
who might be having kids you know in the
near somewhat near future like those
products that are very interesting she's
just like all organic like good products
like that little bed that she has her I
see that like kernels are like a little
burrito like you know good to know yeah
I didn't know those existed
they're everything like her actual
bottle like I didn't know that existed
in like you know what I need to know
that and I want you to make money off of
it
you know I know I love them I really
love them there's um I'm trying to think
like who I don't like and like that's a
couple ambassador nation right now I'm
pretty supportive I think of everyone
Katelyn and Jayson oh yeah everyone
thought they were getting engaged and
they took a trip to the Bahamas which
was like basically a three-day photo
shoot yeah and she wrote a teenaged and
I don't know what it was for but it
looked really nice that I actually
wanted to look into that house or hotel
it was really nice
oh yeah I feel like it's a little too
soon for them to be getting
there and I want them to be unlike a
good normal time like take your time
people release they just moved in
together guys she's got a dog your tie
the water agreed agreed agreed agreed
who else's together um I'm actually so
stoked for paradise I've heard that it's
like the greatest season well it's a
season of Blake being like everyone
turns on buddy that's what I heard so
sad but also so sad you seem really
upset about it and then also Demi okay
who do you think the next Bachelor is a
demi and Demi is out here being she came
out as bisexual yes I think it's gonna
be the first time on paradise where they
had the same sex relationships cool
[ __ ] here for it um I think we'll
actually I have a call but I'm almost
positive that it's right about not about
the bachelor but about power nice
because I did a lot of like pausing my
screen to make sure the news was correct
and stuff so I'm pretty sure I know who
had a G ends up with just based off with
a guess I haven't read one spoiler but
I'm almost positive that it's right that
I'm not gonna tell you okay go back to
UM pack back sorry yeah so Mike Mike
Tyler okay I love Tyler I really do I
just don't see him as a bachelor he's no
bachelor he just isn't he ain't it says
so no faster than final to I think with
between Mike and Peter and honestly like
I would I would be happy with either I
think it's gonna be Mike but I think
that Peter would be the greatest
bachelor in history like I don't I know
them enough cuz I didn't watch anything
that they were in but just based on what
I'm seeing from the world it seems like
the world really wants Mike I've heard
more cries for Mike than I have for
people but in in his defense Mike went
home a bunch of weeks ago you've had
more time to be inundated with that
stuff Peter went home on Monday but how
many Mike was what the fourth like fifth
that's a little too far yeah and like
you say he's been gone for like four
three weeks now like yeah obviously
you're gonna see it everywhere but Peter
you can you didn't know if he won yet to
somebody says I feel like I saw Mike in
the bachelor in paradise promo did
anyone else catch that I didn't catch I
don't know if the timing would have I
don't think he could have done both um I
didn't catch that
I'm not I don't think so but I really
think like I'm if he was Mike or Peter I
would be glad I'm definitely watching
obviously a season of The Bachelorette
reinvigorated me watched a manager like
they needed this season to rally the
troops
obviously if Mike becomes about trying
to be the first black lead yeah in The
Bachelor franchise which is so crazy
she was been around for literally 20
years it's a shame on them and if they
don't do it like they're like it's
embarrassing at this point no it's
embarrassing that they have in and it's
also just like I would say Mike 100% but
then so knowing that they had also such
another great option but maybe maybe
Peter could be like an re comes back
that's sure I always think like one of
these days they're just gonna announce
that Peter crafts as a bachelor like
Peter crafts can be an re who was like
at the time you should have gotten it
but he didn't but like then they kept
him on reserve for a while yeah but then
also and when but late or he was now in
hi tayt like an inspiring choice Oh 100%
like they always know better than we
think
but I know but it's also what's going on
with my voice so apparently think about
it him and his wife I just I went out
searching for stories they settled their
divorce she dropped whatever was
training order charges and it seems like
they're at peace it makes a story still
alarming no it makes it seem like he
just gave her Slyke what she wanted a
settlement and told her to shut her
mouth because like that could bring down
the entire franchise bring down the
entire franchise he seems like an animal
and I've heard awful stories about him
me too for people in the franchise so
this was not shocking yeah and
apparently he's super hands-off thank
God like he's not involved every day on
a day-to-day like he just is like that's
for the best he's just the creator but I
think he's heavily involved in who they
choose as the lead and I think when you
get the lead you meet with my flights
for the first time and I don't think
she's really so like so precious and she
did a great job and she really got her
words together she really did um just
based off of it a little that I've seen
I don't I'm not upset that I didn't want
just season um because really like the
time I got back to you know spend with
my family it's just like you really
can't put money on that like that is so
valuable if you make it a fun thing if
you like see it as like a chore than
whatever but it's like it's definitely a
chore what was I gonna say oh that's
hilarious tweet it's like justice for
the Peters of the bachelor franchises
like Peter yes Peter Krause it is like
literally two amazing men who just can't
win who just can't win yeah every time I
get on a flight now I'm like well
because we were on the flight home and
we were find out that and he finds Delta
like are you kidding and then there was
a young man who came on it and like it
could have been no and they said they
were like Captain Peter oh they did
yet another Peter it was another Peter
but like we heard that and we were like
yeah we're so nervous
get up completely one day one day I
could fly enough um okay I think is that
all we had to recap I mean you don't
want your house size of Beverly Hills
the the final part of the reunion was
[ __ ] whack camille Grammer has lost
her goddamn mind and honestly I would
say she had one of the best walk-offs in
history because she literally took her
dress off and her tits were out it was
the weirdest thing and like no one's
even talking about like the tits of it
all because she unzipped her dress to
take her mic off and she's a litter
couldn't go dress back on Andy came in
followed her she did her talking to Andy
and liked her dress is falling off and
her tits are out like it was so crazy
she's literally lost her mind she was
making absolutely no sense coming for
Denise Richards she was a precious gem
of a woman like don't [ __ ] comfort
Denise Richards she's a professional
housewife she's added so much value to
this franchise um and that's it nothing
really happened it didn't need to be a
three-part reunion I think two would
have sufficed but whatever so gas stream
toast my signal comes out I really
forgot I feel like it was a different
day than when we started this show my
single comes out tonight at midnight
Eastern Time Spotify iTunes like
obviously you can see em on Spotify but
if you couldn't bring me a dollar 29
like I think it'll just be like really
good I want to get on the charts so like
I mean I literally venmo you know
literally I will pay for you really like
so obviously you can stream on Spotify
but like it would really just like hook
me up financially and also just like
reputation wise if you guys could just
like buy it on iTunes but I love you
guys I just want you to enjoy the song
like please know that this song is truly
like it was made for you and I really
feel like you're gonna like it like play
that your pre games play it at your
wedding like I really don't give a [ __ ]
yeah stream toast we'll be at the party
giant we'll be doing a million Instagram
stories from the toasts from girls no
job clubs no jobs so make sure to follow
along
I'm mark Asham a gofer for subbing in
for Jackie Jackie's back tomorrow she's
literally on the plane right now on her
way back from from France the French
camera is taking her brat off she's
coming back to her cigarette and she is
coming back to American camper it's
gonna be great jacket we'll be here for
the party tonight and tomorrow thank you
guys for listening to the morning toast
the Millennial morning show up we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube please give this
video a thumbs up and subscribe if you
are available and if your podcasts are
listening to this as a podcast thank you
so much for your support you can listen
to our podcast anywhere Spotify iTunes
stitcher I Heart Radio basically
everywhere you can also find my song and
make sure to subscribe over there leave
us a nice review about how beautiful and
talented we are thank you guys so much
for the never ending support we're so
glad to be back and we will see you
tomorrow special time 12:30 because of a
feeling we're
a little hungover for the party they
don't want to be able to give it my all
tomorrow tomorrow's release day yeah so
12:30 tomorrow live on YouTube also
available as podcasts love you guys
you